he's Dewayne Haskins the quarterback
from The Ohio State University all right
official height in weight is what 640 26
your nickname Simba Simba Simba come
from them so you know my someone here
growing up and a lot of hair my favorite
is liking so I saw that and I named came
to fruition do you want to keep that
nickname or do you want a new one I
think I might give it it's pretty cool
no I like it I like it I know you're
Nashville today but you're coming back
to DC and then you're not going to be at
the draft you're going you're gonna host
a bowling party why bowling that's how
my family choose a pastime
whether that's bowling or golf cart
racing or what so else we do putt-putt
and stuff like that shuffle you can have
fun with uhm so yeah I'm excited to go
Bowl tomorrow
was there any thought of going to the
draft no how come so I just wanted to
spend time with my family my mentors and
people that helped me along his long
journey so of course the draft was a
tremendous opportunity and I consider it
is but I only get 10 to 15 people to be
able to go with you to the draft so it
wasn't enough tickets for me all right
let's say you get drafted really high
like top 5 do you then finish your
bowling game or do you just leave the
bowling alley I'm a social game good do
you have any idea where you're going
Thursday night honestly I got some
ceilings or yeah I don't know this will
be a very interesting to see all right
give me an idea though like Washington
likes you now it's just us talking here
Giants it could be either were at this
point this sorry
even the Raiders Oh No maybe the Broncos
man narrows possibility down from some
532 to five all right that's not bad but
if I was gonna make up a Haskins Jersey
just hedging my bets which team should I
maybe get a Haskins jersey for a simba
Haskins Jersey you almost said Miami no
oh you didn't okay okay no that's not
okay
okay what mater's what do you what do
you think it is you know it for so long
I thought it was gonna be the Giants and
then it it was there too long and I
thought okay the Giants that maybe
that's not gonna happen that's not based
off anything
I feel like Denver or Washington I can
agree with that you're all right with
that
yeah and you can you skied you like the
snow you you were in Columbus but
there's a little different in Denver
yeah it's very correction when I visited
Denver it got snowed in but it's frozen
in April so all I can imagine what it's
like him to say oh my god what was it
like to meet Elway as crazy as cool I
mean in this process I get to meet
former NFL greats and it's great to me
lol a memory no met Doug Williams it was
crazy to me you know it was cool to be
able to meet LA and get to be around his
presence and I'll get to ask some
questions and stuff like that oh all
right but are you allowed to ask for
autographs or pictures there there's
that night I never had anybody for a
picture never not even think I don't
think that's like an unwritten rule I
think what about autographs - for longer
[Laughter]
Matt that's that's like 1980s 90s stuff
that you don't do that stuff now
maybe if I got drafted their ass were
like asunder is here something would
that would be good yeah favorite
quarterback growing up was who I don't
have like one particular favorite
quarterback
I love the whole bunch of them McNair
McNabb was popular back when I was
younger of course
and I almost remember jake the snake'
plumber he's pretty cool to me
losses out there it was good dumain I've
been around here a long time doing this
I member take the snake and Arizona
State a little older than you he's a
harmless fun to watch you know all those
guys who do you resemble who does your
game best resemble or who do you try to
model it after really yeah well if you
can throw anywhere near the deep ball
that he threw I thought he threw the
prettiest deep ball in NFL history no he
does it just kind of you know flew out
of his head floated out of his hands it
that was great I know you're doing stuff
with Old Spice let me let me hear how
you're doing as a pitchman all right
here's the price hold on hold on let's
everybody that's here is Dwayne Haskins
they call him Simba and here is his
pitch for Ramon's life all right Old
Spice is helping me get ready for the
big stage at the NFL Draft with all new
pressure collection featuring real
benefits and real ingredients like
moisturizer with shea butter relaxed
lavender body wash you can find this
pressure collection on Walmart all the
supplies are giving guys more love
because men have skin too and I'm very
very conscientious of being clean on and
off the field the best smell in the NFL
and if you want to be clean you buy Old
Spice because I normally don't use
deodorant but I'm gonna use it now after
that pitch that's how convincing you
were they're doing thank you
which the car you drive now and what's
the car you're gonna be driving let's
say in a month
I have a Toyota rav4 at least 2018 right
now much so what Carl want to get
because all the nice cars have really
bad my religion don't know I'm really
great on gas so main focus will be to
get mom a car first and go from there
well done okay what is mom gonna get
though mom wants a Mercedes hey I can
hook you up my man cave is sponsored by
mercedes-benz really yeah yeah I'll see
what I can do by the way I was at the
Michigan game this year did you how did
you enjoy that boat whooping that was
good you know how many times I had I got
crushed at Thanksgiving cuz Michigan
would beat Ohio State be like oh yeah
losing record but we won the last seven
eight games so to be excited about that
but did you did you try to rub it in
since it was Michigan no I don't think
so I think we were just having fun with
it and eventually the scoreboard says a
lot of points that's why she ever got
scored on in their school history so
that's pretty cool did you talk to Jim
Harbaugh and all after that game I'd
never exchanged words with him
Harborough since high school so I don't
know I watched the Amazon thing they did
years ago yeah and he wasn't too fond of
me when I came in in the big house and
beat him so I don't know I haven't
talked to him did he recruit you he
recruited me for like two weeks and I
was like I'm not going to that team up
north so Wow
decided to lose elsewhere hey have fun
with the bowling party and enjoy the
experience it'll be over and you you
move on and then all eyes will be on you
is it starting quarterback somewhere in
the league so we appreciate your time
Duane and good luck thank you thank you
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app